key that you need to have to become
successful as a consultant is
quantitative and analytical skills
surely especially in the first years of
your career as a consultant you will
work with the data a lot you will crunch
numbers and Excel in other programs and
a good solid quantitative understanding
is definitely important the tool that
you will use most frequently to Crunch
the numbers is X and indeed and I
definitely think it would be very much
worth your time to improve your access
skills as much as possible because
strong access skills alone can carry you
in your first years in Consulting that
can really make a difference to your
team and therefore also for your career